I would fall into Paradox very very
quickly if I start dictating to you how
to be free right we all know you can't
be forced to be free right but what I
could do instead is ask well in any
given situation how might you increase
the amount of Freedom that's available
to
[Music]
you hi so Sophie um when most people
think about um Authority and Leadership
they tend to think about you know big
calized bodies like the state um but in
your work you think of it slightly
differently could you tell us a bit
about that please yes I do so I work a
lot on um well post-war Anarchist
thought and um in particular I mean
because anarchism is a very broad church
with many different forms of it and I'm
particularly interested in pacifist
forms I'm particularly interested in
those forms that are very Community
Based very Grassroots um very focused
around PE uh people and direct ocracy
and obviously in when you sort of look
at at these sorts of ideas uh these
Notions of leadership and Authority you
know they they're quite they um they
take on of new and challenging forms now
some people sort of think immediately
make the Assumption well it's anarchism
right by definition that means there can
be no leader or no no forms of authority
um and in fact no organization in fact
most for most people anarchism is just
is chaos and it's something to be feared
and something to be um
something to be
avoided but actually the sort of uh
ideas that I look at have a slightly
different take and they say that
actually there's nothing inherently
wrong with leadership in and of itself
but there is something wrong when that
becomes permanent and that becomes
institutionalized um what is more
interesting to these kind of thinkers um
one of the figures I work on for example
is an individual called Colin Ward and
he wrote a book called Anarchy in action
and it was very much based on on how in
our everyday lives in our sort of
workplaces and our communities and our
homes our families and our friendship
groups um we are constantly busy
negotiating or discussing uh working out
what we're going to do how we're going
to do it and we don't actually need to
appoint some permanent forms of
leadership in order to achieve this
sometimes you know sometimes that there
is that presence in some family
structures uh they they cleave to a very
particular form of of um interaction
perhaps as a male head of the family
perhaps a female but actually in many um
places and circumstances you don't have
that so I think
um the interesting thing for me when I
was sort of moving through these ideas
and working through them was to get rid
of this idea you have to eliminate
leadership in this sort of great
fraternal cuddly sense of absolutely
everyone in agreement it's you you know
it's not necessarily you need to get
complete consensus on something it can
be that there is someone who has a
particular strength or a particular
understanding a particular Insight on
something that you want to
achieve and then by all means people
should listen to them or if there is a
sort of natural sense to which they are
able to to direct or guide or facilitate
something happening then by all means
respect that but the big thing is it
doesn't become permanent and that when
things change and change is possibly the
most important factor in this form of
Anarchy um and acknowledge change and
living with the fact that things change
in a meaningful
way at some point somebody else is going
to be better placed to take that role so
that's sort of that's the kind of nuance
to leadership that I think these
Anarchist ideas bring yeah thank you
that makes a lot of sense so um in your
in your answer there you mentioned
direct democracy and obviously you know
this has been discussed in the UK before
um I think maybe the consensus view is
that um even though the ideal of direct
democ rcy is um very worthy it's
something I think people would like to
embody um there's a general consensus
that it's sort of unlikely to work on
the scale of the United Kingdom even
though it might work at more local
levels um could you speak to us about
you know what what does the anaka say to
that kind of worry few interesting um um
points there but yes absolutely it's
generally it's not just that it's sort
of laudable but unrealistic some people
actually very much don't feel it's it's
laudable at all some people um sort of
think it's veering being towards kind of
more dangerous forms of populism and you
can't deny that it does have that within
the tradition there are certain
voluntary groups that have existed in
history um that are spontaneous and
cooperative and and and work for very
very questionable or or frightening
things and we are to some degree seeing
things like that and that's something
that you know I certainly feel that I
need to address and confront and not
evade um the other big um sort of
stereotype that goes with it is that if
it's direct democracy then you're going
to be having lentils for lunch there's
going to be a drum circle and at some
point the incense is going to be lit um
and I'd avoid the brownies if I were you
yep that's in there too that I means
most stereotypes kind of have sufficient
grains of Truth in order to keep them
perpetuating and these are sort of
factors that do put people off I think a
lot of people don't realize the extent
to which they're already practicing
direct democracy and just not realizing
it like I said in my um previous uh
previous response on the question of
leadership so many times if you are
capable of being within a group of
friends and organizing something or
deciding on something then you're
actually capable like the the raw skills
and processes and mechanics of that um
you've got them they're in there so it's
not so I sort of push back on the on the
on the notion that it's impossible human
beings living together and trying to
work that out is in essence what we're
talking about here now you also
mentioned in the question sort of okay
but how would this work on a United
Kingdom scale and indeed you know how
would you work that on a kind of global
scale we we have to sort of look at the
issue these direct democracy
communities such as might have been en
visaged by someone like Jean Jac rouso
for example even he back in the sort of
18th century said well it's too late now
modern societ modern industrial society
is too complex we can't go back to nice
little cozy peasant communes um no
matter how hard we try um and part of me
is attracted to the cozy little peasant
commune apart from the fact that you
know having grown up in a very rural
part of part of Britain um and the idea
of being enclosed in that Community it's
not all candle foot people that's all
I'm going to say um
so yeah interesting notion now the sort
of anism I'm committed to I could speak
to you about Federated communities or
you know and and the the fact that far
from being an acronis you know these
sorts of models of federation so for
example you've got kokkin notion of
Federated communities slightly updated
by I think of gdh Cole in the mid in the
mid-century he talked about Guild
socialism and those sorts of Notions how
you organize sort of a complex modern
industrial society by through sort of
syndicates or workers control there are
all those models out there and they're
useful to be able to sort of present the
sort of anarchism I um that interests me
the most doesn't really like to kind of
paint ideal social orders for me it's
always far more of a of a practice and
in this in this sense I sort of cheat a
little bit so I say well I don't need to
worry about how you would necessarily
organize or institutionalize direct
democracy de direct democracy that sort
of implies that that's it's direct
democracy is sort of a means to an an
end like the end being you know this
perfect social order where everything's
jolly and lovely and equal and just and
all those good things now that would be
nice but actually I sort of come in
slightly differently and say well for me
direct democracy is kind of the end and
the means Allin one so if I can see any
opportunity in any space existing spaces
and cre and and new ones you know but uh
it's perfectly possible within existing
spaces where people can just increase
the amount of democratic practices that
are available to them with existing
means now that to me is a is a possibly
more interesting interesting angle
although it does feel to some people
like I'm evading the question of how it
might work on a large scale but I sort
of think I don't I would I would fall
into Paradox very very quickly if I
start dictating to you how to be free
right we all know you can't be forced to
be free right but what I could do
instead is ask well in any given
situation how might you increase the
amount of Freedom that's available to
you and that would be Good Start yeah so
so it's about um taking the practices
and some of the skills and the
activities that we're already engaged in
because the whole thing about direct
democracy if it's not voluntary and
spontaneous then it's not direct
democracy so if you invent a new system
and say to everyone this is going to
work you have to do it like this
now that's actually very um it's a
logical fallacy it sort of it collapses
in on itself
immediately uh you have to where people
are actually at with what they're doing
with where they already are and
respecting them as as already thinking
and intelligent beings that that are
capable of making decisions are capable
of cooperating may not want to do it in
the patent or to the order that you've
got in mind and that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean you tolerate anything of
course it's an exchange it's a
discussion democracy is that it's not
for me democracy is not about achieving
a complete consensus and that's the only
means by which it can function right
right right it's actually about how you
have conflict that's creative rather
than catastrophic good so so I wanted to
bring you back to the worry that you
mentioned which which is that there are
um some instances of the past and
unfortunately maybe in the future as
well of people using these kinds of
methods but coming to form groups that
have ideologies or moral views which we
now find to be generally
um and I guess the question I have is
how are we to you know without sort of
disturbing the Democratic nature of this
process how are we to nudge our way off
that path so for example I think when
you nodded your head to it the um the
the new Italian leader is you know
further right than maybe some people are
hoping across Europe um and there are
those sentiments um and I think they
need to be taken seriously as a matter
of Dem ratic practice right this is an
embodiment of what the people of Italy
wanted um but you know I for one I'm
concerned and I get the sense of many
other people too so how how are we going
to use this direct Democratic procedure
to nudge away from some results um yeah
for
me so I think you're you're going
somewhere it's s really interesting here
because and the difference maybe in the
first instance between liberal democracy
is a noun for a set of Institutions and
a historical formation a sociopolitical
formation um that sort of
takes acknowledges or takes its cues
from from particular ideas of ancient
Greece or the ancient um Greek world for
example and has had the majority of its
concentrated development in the west and
in America and places like that and and
now finds itself facing a lot of
questions and and
challenges and then there is a certain
degree of irony to which in order to
protect itself this liberal democracy
capital L capital D proper noun has to
actually kind of to what extent does it
feel that it needs to abandon um
democracy as an adjective or a verb for
a certain way of practicing and being
and and sort of deliberating on
decisions which is what we're
essentially talking about when we talk
meaningfully about
democracy and It's Tricky one of so my
first protocol with the this the the The
Great Wave of populism as it's being
referred to F first of all I I think
it's difficult to think about it that
way and get any and get much further
along along the
tracks the leader I mean the and it's
something the political right has always
been remarkably good at and the
political left has always been
remarkably bad at the political right
have an ear to the ground More Than
People realize and they very good at
picking up perfectly concerns or fears
or worries that are not in them in and
of themselves completely unreasonable
and turning them into a very
well-crafted rhetorical political
campaign uh Margaret thater was you know
she uh Someone I used to work on quite
carefully was the the historian Raphael
Samuel and he once said uh Margaret that
just stole the left libertarian best
lines and used them and used them for
for the right she understood what people
were objecting to and played that to her
advant AG a lot of these movements are
simply recognizing that many people feel
very anxious worried they are conscious
that they're living in systems that
don't seem to be working that there's a
a disjunction or um Distortion between
what they are being told should be the
case and what they are actually
experiencing in their
lives again if you sort of drill in and
start trying to avoid sort of mass or
mob thinking when it comes to populism
you'll have a tiny small minority of
people who are hardcore committed to
these views and a larger group of people
who don't are not finding any other
forms of expression or
representation anywhere else and they
are being welcomed and they're being
given dignity and respect by these sort
of these other sort of sources of power
so they're gravitating towards
them I'm not sure like so in my ideal
um having more democracy right now
democracy the adjective the
verb would be the best way of protecting
the liberal democracy proper noun as a
system um that would be what I would
would
Advocate that we have come so far away
from a culture where we are willing to
listen to people's fears or concerns
especially
when they check or go or run counter to
what we want to
hear and so that's for me that's that's
an important starting
place but it's a frightening one because
obviously it takes time takes time to
win that respect and create those um
cultures of discussion and we are living
at times where uh we don't know how much
time we have for certain
things yeah I mean that I think that's
that sounds right and the the Insight
that the right has been better at
listening to concerns that people have
and turning them into a political
campaign that Rings very true and I me
we saw that in 2016 yeah exactly exactly
so obviously thater but um it's
happening right now it's happening it's
happening as we speak uh in the cabinet
office um so uh I thought we could turn
to some biographical questions um so
You' spoken in the past about your sort
of libertarian beginnings and I wondered
if you could if you could give us a sort
of potted history of how you came to
this interest and anarchism and how you
came to these
views so I was definitely an anarchist
before I knew I was an anarchist um my
mom was a teacher and she uh she made
the Cardinal error of teaching both my
brother and I to read when we were very
very little before we started school and
saying to us if you can read the world's
open to you you won't you know you won't
need anything else oh she should said
that um I tried school and found
that I didn't like like instinctively I
reacted against the regiment the
regimented nature of the day the fact
that I was in cloes the fact I was told
what to read when to read how to read it
before I even had anything resembling a
sort of critical or an analytical
language for these things it was just
and I think this is probably the case
for many people it's an instinctive gut
reaction and I had a few choices
um I could do what many of my peers did
and sort of it was the Prototype of
quiet quitting so you just go there and
you just get through the day and you
just wait for break time lunch time and
home time those are the three highlights
of the
day or another group that just um kind
of sort of uh disrupted their own lives
by by basically rebelling being
um badly behave what have you I decided
to take a third option that that was
simply I just w away I I I continued to
um reject or refuse it was uh yes it was
my first example of resistance I suppose
and uh I was very lucky I had
understanding parents and here's the
here's where the direct democracy came
in they were both of them willing to
hear my point of view even as a child
and the the point you can I was always
told you you can make your case you're
going to receive criticisms on it but
you must if you can make your case if
you can put your point point across we
will listen that was the deal no
guarantees and agreement but certainly I
got a hearing and so one way or another
somehow I managed to sort of bumble
struggle through so the the you know 18
years I I took the exams fairly
independently so I had a very in andout
very checkered very minimal relationship
with formal education and now I come to
look back and I think that that was sort
of extremely important from a very young
age I got very used to being very
self-reliant from deciding what I was
going to read how I was going to
learn if I had been forced through
school I think my passion and enthusiasm
for all that sort of thing would have
been completely extinguished pretty much
annihilated by the time I got to 18 um
the fact that I was choosing what to
pursue and
how and in that process found that
things that I wouldn't normally have
wanted to do like mathematics or science
they weren't sort of natural things for
me but through needing to know wanting
to know about certain things I sort of
quite organically found myself just
being interested in everything and
seeing the value and the and and the
potential value of of everything so that
in a very everyday boring non- exiting
way um was the roots of it and that's
why I suppose when I come ac across
radicalism capital r glamorous Chic you
know sort of um with all your sort of
factions and groups and that that's
that's not that's not the sort of
culture that um that I kind of gravitate
towards there it is strongly sort of
individualist in my case but never sort
of in the isolated individual it's my
way of constantly moving through the
world and being a part of the
relationships and the interactions that
I'm in rather than simply going along
with anyone else's other pattern of life
that leads me to my final question so I
wanted to ask and in fact there might
actually be two questions here now so um
obviously I'm sure there are lots of
thinkers that you would have liked to
meet that you never had the chance um so
I was going to ask um what sort of
historical Anarchist figure would you
like to have a sort of lively dinner
conversation with and what would you
choose to speak about but perhaps there
are two questions in the sense that
maybe one answer for a younger version
of yourself you know who was
experiencing this passion for certain
projects and certain things end in
school education stifling and then now
someone who's embraced this knowingly
you know self- knowledge of what you are
and how it fits with anarchism and where
you fit in in the anarchist
Community well
[Music]
um so my younger self once I got to the
point where I realized that there could
actually be sort of politicized ways of
talking about how I was feeling and
going towards those early kind of that
classic George Woodcock history of
anarchism which uh sort of I I I I don't
think any any student could have got
through the 60s without having a copy I
would hope not but that was actually
really important and that book is I mean
within the anarchist Cannon it does the
useful job of setting out the ancestors
so it's got kokkin in there and it's got
banin and it's got prudon and it's got
tolto and you it's not compulsory to
come from Russia and have a great beard
if you're an anarchist but it helps and
I suppose for me any figure from that
book I was a bit disappointed that there
weren't too many sort of really
interesting sort of female figures um
Emma Goldman is obviously a sort of
interest but but I suppose when I was
younger that was quite important to have
this sort of sense of a a deep a deep
history um and these quite glamorous
exciting figures with their sort of big
ideas and mutual Aid and so I suppose if
I was to narrow it down when I was
younger I think it it would it would
have to be kokkin thing but now actually
in the sort of work I do I I do a lot of
work through intellectual biography
because to me it's a really useful way
of showing how the individual is never
an isolated private separate entity that
actually if you look at biography if we
tell the story of Our Lives we can't do
that without showing all the social
relationships and interactions that go
into to forming any one life and so the
thinkers I look at now um are really
interesting from that respect so Colin
Ward for example Raphael Samuel EP
Thompson um and at the moment I'm doing
a lot of work on fig like who you
wouldn't even and who would never have
called themselves Anarchist people like
gdh Cole or Isaiah Belin now before I'm
I'm not but I'm not saying for one
moment that they were anarchists but
what's really interesting about what
these people are trying to do is what
I'm trying to do it's work out how to be
politically committed without having to
have all the answers and work out how
actually
democracy the conditions for democracy
as a concept are satisfied by practice
you don't always have to have the
finished result to say that you are um
you you are experiencing radical
democracy brilliant thank you very much
I think we might wrap up there thank you
for coming my pleasure for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
The Institute of Arts and ideas at
iitv